[Music]  look at this all those years in the big  city we find a guy we're living the  dream  maybe there's a dream then everything  just blew up big flash like a pink light  or actually I don't even know what color  it was it wasn't like any color I'd ever  seen before looks like a meteorite  he was radioactive I mean it's one face  right meteorite to Germany no more  dangerous than ordinary rocks okay  something I think just disappear  did you plant those no wart here for a  sec oh god who's talking to you it's in  the static it's in the moisture it's in  here is out there  and what's out there is in here now  everything's under control  nothing from the meteorite changes  everything around it it's just a color  believe me no I don't wanna believe  anymore  [Applause]  [Music]  everything's gonna be a-okay  [Music]  you  [Music]